les deux jeunes hommes installés côte à
côte tous les deux le dos courbé dans le
box des accusés son cousin ils se
connaissent très bien aujourd'hui ils se
renvoient la balle ils s'accusent
mutuellement d'avoir mis le feu aux
poubelles du foyer adoma aucun des deux
ne revient pour l'instant sur ses
positions leurs avocats espèrent un
revirement de situation
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il se prend
vraiment une vérité est en pleine figure
comme on dit familièrement qui prend la
pleine mesure de cet événement et je
doute beaucoup qu'il qu'il veuille
continuer a indiqué que son cousin
serait responsable pas lui je pense
qu'il a compris effectivement que le
débat n'est pas là qu'ils étaient tous
les deux présents qu'il ya une part de
responsabilité qui est partagé le plus
impressionnant c'est finalement le
changement d'aspect physique de rémi
kukulinski après trois ans de
traitements antidépresseurs
anxiolytiques et autres et trois ans
derrière les barreaux l'accusé âgé
aujourd'hui de 21 ans a pris près de 60
kg il apparaît très fragile très
affaibli le président de la cour lui a
même demandé s'il serait capable
physiquement de suivre les débats
on le sentait
aujourd'hui très précaire santé mentale
surtout très précaire il est sous
médicaments ça va être très difficile
c'est pas qu'il ne veut pas s'exprimer
c'est qu'il va avoir du mal à le faire
près d'une cinquantaine de victimes
étaient présentes ce matin des parties
civiles qui n'ont pas forcément un
sentiment de rancoeur aujourd'hui on
pardonne parce que y'a pas pour la même
raison c'est parce que on sait qu'un bon
d'une loi il avait payé c'est tout et on
passait on passe à autre chose c'est
bien il n'y a pas de rancoeur non pas du
tout pas du tout mais pas encore du tout
et on n'aura jamais cet après midi les
enquêteurs sont revenus sur les
antécédents des deux accusés rémi
kukulinski et nicolas doze raïs avait
déjà mis le feu à plusieurs poubelles
notamment à précy sous thil ou encore à
semur-en-auxois quelques jours avant le
drame les deux garçons décrit comme
perdu et instable n'en n'était donc pas
à leur premier coup d'essai et était
déjà attiré par ce genre d'acte
incendiaires